so we all agree that there are a lot of
countries that have the potential to
emerge that deserve to be in these
categories but at the same time many of
that that have been in those categories
also didn't deserve to be a lot of
people who talk about the bricks today
actually say bix they've already dropped
out Russia and that's 30 years before
they were supposed to get there in the
first place so one can be highly
suspicious especially given events in
the Middle East Goldman Sachs included
Nigeria Egypt Iran and Pakistan in its
next eleven any number of those really
are in the brink of collapse right now
so let's talk about which ones are going
to submerge I certainly am less sanguine
about the Middle East some number one
they have very large population
disaffected people but the other issue
is that they're incredibly the under
diversify their absolutely obsessed with
oil which perhaps in the short term is
not such a bad thing but you no longer
terms is not a strategy for long-term
economic growth on the other region that
keeps me up at night is certainly
sub-saharan Africa it's got you know in
terms of resources again capital in
terms of labour markets and in terms of
the ability to absorb productivity it
should be right up there in the front
but I you know the the obsession with an
aid culture I think is really hindering
economic progress in that continent I
would take exception on sub-saharan
Africa we're seeing incredible growth
just in the last five to ten years in
multinational corporations that are
based in sub-saharan Africa because of
the liberalisation of the economies
their creation increasingly of a middle
class and we've seen enormous gains in
education there too now if you ask me
where we might see trouble it's in the
ones that have already gotten as much
steam as they could out of the big
trends that really get you off the
bottom rungs of the growth ladder the
rural to urban migration getting people
off farms and into factories and the
tendency to be able to copy products and
export them more cheaply some countries
can't do that anymore oh isn't India
overrated I mean it has a youth bulge
come to think of it people say it's as a
demographic sweet spot with so many
young people entering the labor force
but unless you create labor for that
workforce they could wind up being
disaffected masses such as what we're
seeing in the Middle East absolutely I
think one of the assumptions people tend
to make very casually and development is
that all good things come together all
bad things come together the good thing
that's happening in India right now the
extraordinary thing is the the
unleashing of ambition in a massive
society that was very hierarchically
ordered
in which now a lot of people in theory
are being told you can be anyone you
want to become what people don't realize
is those same people who are being
filled these new ambitions have much
higher expectations now and any lack of
opportunity is now perceived as a slight
and you actually destabilize countries
when you raise a lot of people's
expectations much faster than you can
save them so most overrated economies
with all due respect is probably India
for a lot of the reasons that that Anna
just outlined they have good
demographics in the interim I think that
fundamentally they still have a lot of
issues around corruption and
infrastructure is outlays I think it's
something that would be worried about
Argentina is way up there because they
are being neglected in terms of foreign
direct investments simply because the
country is still so corrupt I've no
doubt that argentina had a hand in
creating that label of vista so the big
attack on the end but i think what we
all agree is that even if a country gets
a rose and its locker and is included in
one of these sexy acronyms for emerging
markets it really still does have to
prove its fundamentals and that's what
makes these countries so vital to
determining the future of the global
economy thanks very much for your
insights more on that and other relevant
topics at big thing calm